what do women bring to the table lately
I've been seeing this question asked
everywhere and if you're asking that
question you don't understand women or
relationships at all let me prove it to
you using the table analogy if the table
is the relationship a man's
responsibility is typically to put the
meat on the table and the woman's
responsibility is typically to set the
table
what would the meat be in this regard I
did
hey
don't kick shame shank
um so if I were to imagine look I guess
this sounds very traditional so if I
would imagine what the meat is in this
consideration it's probably about the
income money money income yeah you know
the the resources yeah the thing is like
if you know anything about the ding
landscape today women are generally out
and earning men so what are these
relationships that our men are bringing
the meat to the table it's not the women
who are also bringing the meat to the
table what are these relations well just
right there
that dude took a lot of elements from
different eras
sure to just saying well traditionally
yeah but we're not we're not in that
that's not so so that's not the time so
most people need two parent households
or like income so yeah exactly it was
not the case for you yeah absolutely she
was bringing to me for some time or more
of it yeah you bringing it yeah
absolutely so bad but and right now that
the society is not made to be to have
only it's not made for one person to
typically it's not made for just only
one person to bring to me this red [ __ ]
with these guys prices I said who can
afford to only have one person making
money what I said unless you don't live
like like you live far far whatever
whatnot but at the end of the day that's
what it is except if you have like a
ha ha earning job and I'm talking about
like 200 and and up so right there and
there and what that means is that a
woman civilizes a man if it wasn't for
women most of you guys would be living
in a one-bedroom apartment with a double
bed a single pillow one blanket one
chair in your living room and a sick ass
gaming setup it would be efficiency only
I know how it is
women's adopt a civilized man
what are you [ __ ] running
around here like moogly waiting for a
girl to come through and Entertain You
what are you guys only clean because
women
listen
I have tenants
and and no it's not true that choosing
only girls will make your apartment
cleaner
in any type of way we're talking about a
new generation of people that don't
click that don't clean and that don't
cook Okay so
no no again
I just want to say like what were you
Savages then you met a woman then you
became I feel like all these people
watch the same Jordan Peterson video and
then they all just like interpret it
completely differently queen of his job
is to civilize men huh what are you
talking about
what they mean
let's talk about like on a Metro scale
or like on a micro scale like I want to
I don't understand what this I'm trying
to see
I don't think there's anything to see
like what do you guys living like
[ __ ] Jason Momoa and Aquaman just
[ __ ] biking around town not what is
this I don't think who's getting
civilized I don't understand I was like
not everybody's a gamer bro like listen
you'd be single for years not see women
and still not be a gamer bro it's not
because you're not seeing women that
your apartments are hot mess and you're
not making an effort to clean anything
up or maintain stuff bruh listen I love
my [ __ ] bed
I may try about nice threads nice thread
count I don't remember like 32 000
thread count I don't know but that [ __ ]
sound nice why not because women can
sleep in it because I go to bed in that
[ __ ] and I love it and it's a big bit
it's a big bit and I like the pillow I
got I made sure I got the nice
therapeutic bed I didn't do that for
women no you got it back too apparently
it's like guys I understand some dudes
do everything for women or want to like
do all the good things in life for women
like yo do something like that [ __ ] for
yourself
I don't understand
but a lot of a lot of dudes that I know
that live alone they do [ __ ] for
themselves but this [ __ ] is is top-notch
yeah so whatever
um yeah the shortcuts are real I wish I
had something to help me with my credit
when I was younger and I mess up my
credit if that's your case I might have
the thing for you yes absolutely we have
the extra card the extra card is not a
credit card it's not a credit card it's
a debit card how do you better your
credit with the extra card it's really
simple so you of course get the extra
card and then you link it to your bank
account and you do everyday purchases
you auto pay it when on the next
business day at the end of the month
extra reports all those payments to
bureaus helping you build your credit
and on top of that you have redeemable
points that you can get on the extra
card that means that you use the card to
build your credit and earn up to one
percent in Reward Points it's a
win-win-win-win situation basically go
on the link below get your extra card
today and better your credit and I'm not
saying that a woman's job is just to
bring Furniture in your house I'm saying
that a good woman won't let you play
video games 12 hours a day because
there's more to life women see your
potential they see what you can be
doesn't funny women always say don't
marry potential
don't be very potential don't date
potential and when they harp on you it's
because you're not doing what you're
supposed to be doing as a man women see
you they see you at your worst times the
they see the parts of you that other
people don't see and by some miracle
choose to love you anyways and through
that love for you they will push you to
realize that potential that they see in
you and also they do this sort of
instinctually it's like a part of their
process of selecting a mate like they're
looking for the potential in men that's
right that's right all them gold diggers
out there they love a potential all
right
but hey maybe he's talking about select
women these are like good amazing women
only so that's a white Dairy Jackson
I don't know what this guy is and they
see it they see it in you and when
you're not doing what you're supposed to
be doing they [ __ ] at you and give you
a hard time they and until you like
straighten up and realize it they help
you realize your potential some of them
some of them if they're living with you
and they see that you are squandering
your potential it's going to come out of
them in very interesting ways they're
going to nag you they're going to harp
on you they're going to be upset with
you yo get the [ __ ] out of here man take
all your [ __ ] [ __ ] take take your
Build-A-Bear suit okay take your whole
set up and get the [ __ ] out of here this
[ __ ] said feel the person no no what is
this guy talking about they're gonna
nail you they're gonna harp on you to
make you reach your potential what is
all this
I was done I was done a few minutes ago
so I'm what is this mythical I'm good
I'm good now I'm good now
she's on your case if she's a good woman
the reason why she's bothering you and
sexually won't stop nagging you when you
don't want to do what she thinks you
should be doing because that's your
potential and she sees you better than
you see yourself the reason why she does
that
she's a good woman and she rather you
Reaper potential she's here to civilize
your Savage ass who's been playing Call
of Duty what is this what is this
character
so this is gonna get you like you'll
have to get your potential because she
sees what you can do which you can do
better yeah
all right I'm gonna post this it's gonna
give me a lot of [ __ ]
it's only because she sees your
potential how you are how you can be if
she nags too much that's what she brings
to the table and that's why with my
79.99 course you can learn how to make
your man reach his potential and that's
what we're here to tell you guys ladies
civilized these Savage men you are
civilization they are the jungle you are
here to bring them to a better place
it's nothing other than that it's not
Derek Jackson it's Carter Johnson
the Y version that's all that is that's
it I just
look even like the whole premise of the
beginning was already whack off the top
like it's just not feasible yeah it's
like first off women bring the meat men
bring the meat that's just a fact of
life like I don't know what this
mythical land is that where these people
live in where it's like just the dudes
or the breadwinner that's not true and
it hasn't been true for a long time and
like secondly if you move from there
it's like where's this assumption that
dudes are uncivilized like but you don't
think there's a bunch of dudes out there
who don't live clean healthy lives I
know them personally I know what's
happening I know women to do I also know
some messy ass women who when I go to
visit the place I'm like [ __ ] you're
not civilized
by your definition of like this whole
dirty heart I don't know it's too much
characters and this is what I get this
is always when it comes back to
shortcuts
all of these dating coaches or [ __ ]
Guru type people everything is black and
white yep right everything is man does
this women does that women are civilized
men are savages you know men play Call
of Duty for 12 hours and they're dirty
and they don't claim they got one
bedroom that's what they run women do
this it's like it's more no it's not the
reality of the world
we can't afford for that to be around
because it wouldn't function what do you
think anything else you wanna know what
I said this is this just this is Cam you
just stop stop
I don't think I got anything else I
don't even want to watch the rest of
this guys no I don't I don't no yeah
it's not gonna get better we're not
gonna get a new perspective on this
We're not gonna get something new that's
what it is unless you tell me there's a
Twist at the end and he's like psych
[ __ ] ain't [ __ ] get money
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] all right I don't agree but if I
went to his comments I bet you was a
bunch with me like this man takes it no
no no it's a great marketing Ploy yeah
right here into Pander and to be like
men are dumb animals who need to be
cleaned after or whatever and women of
the Civilized saviors it's a fantastic
selfie but again I want you guys to keep
the pattern with all these dating gurus
one gender is generally to blame and one
gender does one thing terribly the other
one does the other thing very it's
always like that with these people